ouais alors trinh xuan thuan donc je
rappeler que cet astrophysicien et au
début vous raconter ce que vous faites
et on s'aperçoit que aujourd'hui vous ne
passez plus votre temps comme vos
prédécesseurs avec une l'oeil rivé à la
lunette l'image de la semaine classique
a bien changé c'est vrai on le public
s'imagine toujours que l'astronome assis
dans le noir dans un froid glacial
suivante les scop
mais c'est plus vrai parce que vraiment
l'astronomie s'est développé dans se
développer d'autres yeux parce que
l'univers est mais toutes sortes de
lumière pas seulement la lumière optique
le fait que nous soyons sensiblement la
lumière optique c'est un effet de
l'évolution darwinienne parce que le
soleil ait aimé la plupart de sa ligne
en optique
mais l'univers bien sûr aimé dans toutes
sortes de lumière allumée radio la
lumière des rayons x les rayons gamma la
lumière infrarouge tout ça et tout ça ça
nous apporte les informations sur
l'univers et pour découvrir la richesse
et la beauté de l'hiver il faut que
l'astronome exporte océan de lumière
donc il s'est construit les yeux soit
sur terre des télescopes un art où se
télescopent radio ou soin des yeux
satellisé c'est à dire parce que là
l'atmosphère justement pour pour nous
protéger contre les cancers par exemple
ce top ultra violet donc il ya beaucoup
de travail qui nous vient de l'espace
donc pour observer ses rayons
ultraviolets il faut donc porter des
télescopes sur orbite et à l'air pur et
sur les stades avec des satellites
notre livre est passionnant étonnant est
risquée parce que non seulement vous
raconter la vie des histoires de la
lumière des étoiles et bruges aux mais
aussi vous nous raconter l'histoire du
big bang comme si vous y aviez assisté
et l'histoire même de la fin de
l'univers c'est ce que vous faites dans
le prospectus
oui d'abord une remarque une chose c'est
que vous parlez toujours 2 milliards
d'années le milliard des toiles de
milliards de galaxies vraiment vous ne
parlez que de milliards ont l'impression
des astrophysiciens vous êtes des
milliardaires
non c'est vrai c'est prince est vraiment
l'homme s'est beaucoup rapetisser dans
l'espace et dans le temps à partir de ce
20e c'est parce que au début du 20e
siècle connaissait même pas l'existence
de galaxy galaxy c'est un ensemble de
200 milliards de soleils 100 milliards
de synergies de 102 par la gravité et en
connaissant milliards de galaxies dans
l'univers est donc tout ça s'est
développé depuis le début de ce siècle
et c'est vrai que nous nous aurons avec
les milliards d'années et les billards
dans la lumière parce que bien sûr la
lune est embêtant pour nous parvenir et
donc mais est ce que c'est une
représentation dans votre cerveau c'est
à dire d une galaxie c'est des milliards
de soleils et il ya des milliards de
galaxies anciennes intellectuels noirs
qui travaillent même qui les observent à
travers les télescopes c'est surtout si
c'est un concept intéressant interclubs
parce que vraiment ça dépasse nos jambes
habituel non le cadre habituel bien sûr
le bon sens habituel cesser complètement
perdu mais donc alors je vous poser
quelques questions dont les réponses
sont dans le livre bien entendu mais
c'est pour l'info bien sûr parce que je
j'ai mal à la fin d'une émission comme
celle ci c'est que les téléspectateurs
aient appris beaucoup de choses comme
moi j'ai appris beaucoup de choses en
lisant vous livre alors pourquoi le ciel
est noir alors qu'il ya plein de plein
air a fait plein de des toiles avec
beaucoup de lumière sauf ça oui voilà ça
c'est une question qui intrigue avait
beaucoup de cosmologistes les
cosmologies sont les gens qui étudie
l'univers dans son ensemble et c'est une
question très valable parce qu'il ya
tellement des toits dans l'univers comme
vous dites est donc le ciel doit être
aussi brillant la nuit que le jour si il
y à une infinité des toiles parce que où
que le regard se tourne
il devra rencontrer obligatoirement une
étoile donc être le ciel doit être aussi
brillant que le soleil pendant le jour
et pourtant les noirs nous avons la nuit
et donc la réponse est venue seulement
avec la découverte du big bang l'univers
donc a eu un début donc il n'est pas et
finement dans le temps c'est à dire
qu'il n'ya pas une infinité des toiles
justement donc il ya un début la lumière
met du temps pour ne pas revenir alors
il le plus loin qu'on peut regarder ces
15 milliards d'années lumière et donc et
puis les étoiles ont une vie
comme mais une vie comme les humains
c'est-à-dire qu'il tenait à ce qu'il
vive le rythme mais sur des échelles de
milliards d'années donc mais c'est fini
tout ça c'est fini c'est pas infini
comme donc donc ça pose plus le problème
justement d'une impunité alors
d'ailleurs quand on l'est quand vous
racontez vos expériences ont
l'impression que l'astronome et moins un
voyageur dans l'espace qu'un voyageur
dans le temps exactement c'est ça qui
était exactement parce que la lumière
mais luttant pour ne pas revenir et on
les informations de l'hiver nous
parvient toujours avec un peu de retard
la lumière du soleil
mais oui minutes pour pour nous venir
meilleure la plus proche soleil de
quatre années la lumière la plus proche
galaxy 2 millions d'années la gare si
andromède par exemple aux premiers
balbutiements de l'humanité et
maintenant avec les plus grands
télescopes on peut revenir jusqu'au
temps jusqu'aux je dirais peut-être deux
tirs du temps du big bang c'est à dire
10 milliards d'années lumière
c'est à dire vraiment remonter le temps
les dettes et les stores sont des
machines à remonter les temps c'est
savoir plus plus on va on remonte le
temps et plus on va vers la nouveauté
alors papa la nouveauté c'est à dire on
voyait on voyait les objets tels qu'ils
étaient des miliciens
on va vers la naissance voilà voilà bien
la naissance
voilà exactement c'est comme que c'est
comme ça qu'on est justement et puis il
y a une une sorte de lumière qui nous
disent englobe maintenant qui parvient
justement des trois cents 300 mille
années après le big bang justement c'est
justement ces notes de musique que cette
que la nature nous envoie que j'appelle
la mélodie d'ailleurs et une d'essayer
la preuve que l'univers a commencé par
une grande explosion
il y avait aussi un mot là aussi des
choses étonnantes et alexis vous avez
dit c'est un milliard de renom 100
milliards de solages soumis absolue
ensemble le plus et vous montrer qu'une
galette une galaxie forte de toutes ces
milliards cela peut porter directement
une autre galaxie
mais à une vitesse au rôle de quelques
centaines kilomètres par seconde
et oui mais alors ces déflagrations
frontale non non non il ya beaucoup
d'espacé entre les entre les étoiles
parce que comme je vous dis l'étoile la
plus proche du soleil c'est ces quatre
années lumière donc il a comment ça se
passe une déflagration mais comprend
elle se rend compte
c'est et s'interpénètrent l'irrigation
composé de soleil dont qui
s'interpénètrent
et puis bon il passe le gaz peut-être le
gaz d'hydrogène et d'hélium qui est jeté
des étoiles peut peut avoir une
collision pouvait être éjectée des
galaxies mais les étoiles
s'interpénètrent ont par exemple dans
quatre milliards et demi d'années la
garantie en tomettes qui vient vers nous
justement maintenant en ce moment bah va
entrer en collision avec notre galaxie
ah bon oui et donc mais il y aura
d'autres catastrophes vous savez le
soleil s'éteindre à tout ça mais c'est
fantastique et friedel bing bang
oui c'est vrai vous raconter ça mais
c'est quand même une théorie l'assister
dans l'aude et man là dessus bien sûr
ils sont se dit s'il est une théorie
mais qui jusqu'ici vérifie toutes les
données expérimentales et ses salles en
sciences il faut toujours une théorie un
paradis pour pau pour travailler pour ce
contenu
armand sauf le début le début le t6
parce qu'avant le monde
ah oui on sait justement il ya ce qu'on
appelle un mur à mur de planck justement
à 10 puissance moins 43 secondes c'est à
dire 1 / pis vous savez civile 43 0 non
mais ce sont des chiffres inimaginable
même pour la solution que je suis et
donc on sait pas parce que là bas les la
force de gravité qui régit l'infiniment
grand
qui dans l'univers maintenant et les
français nucléaire qui régit le monde
des atomes sont à pied égal il n'y a pas
de théorie et maintenance est définie
par deux théories complètement
différente donc la relativité d'un
franchissement qui définit qui lance une
enfant et puis la mécanique quantique
qui défilent alors il ya deux théories
c'est en dehors du big bang
oui et bimbo gars vous raconter ça je le
répète comme si vous aviez assisté vous
donner les temps c'est bon mais en même
temps vous avez le lait de dire que
c'est une théorie à laquelle tous les
cosmologues c'est xavier simplement
parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres qu'il ya
eu d'autres mais c'est moins convaincant
il ya d'autres mélodies quand même que
les gens aussi décomposé
mais c'est moins beaucoup moins
convaincant et c'est surtout il n'arrive
pas à expliquer il ya un chapitre aussi
sur l'univers été fermés ou est il
ouvert
et de toute façon dans les deux cas
l'avenir ne s'annonce pas très radieux
pour nous sur l'inter soit nous aurons
dans une froideur glaciale
oui soit nous nous mourrons alain
bazille infernal c'est à dire le big
bang va pas l'univers qui est en action
sur maintenant vas afin de rayon maximum
et pour s'effondrer les tout ce fin
lettré cas là si tout ça vont
s'agglomérer de nouveau tout redeviendra
lumière les
mais vous vous êtes plutôt un univers
ouvert je suis pas plus tôt c'est ce que
les mesures actuelles tendent à prouver
vous savez il suffit de trois atomes par
mètre cube dans l'univers pour basque
pour faire basculer le destin de
l'univers et c'est pas beaucoup parce
qu'un grand d'euros ces 10 puissance 23
grattant le nombre d'avogadro et trois
atomes par mètre cube c'est rien du tout
mais il suffirait de plus de trois
atomes d'hydrogène par mètre cube pour
stopper l'expansion de l'univers
maintenant et que tout revienne vers
nous et puis oui mais de répondre un big
crunch
mais quand un an seul point quand on lit
votre livre se dit que il a fallu aussi
la d1000 hier je suppose de hasard pour
que l'homme existe soit interne ou je
crois pas que c'est par hasard justement
que je crois que justement savez là en
physique ont défini les choses parce
qu'on apprend par des lois physiques et
qui sont donc décrit par des concentrons
davantage dénombre ce que je dis dans le
livre
et puis aussi par des conditions
initiales et ça les astrophysiciens ont
joué avec sa dent ils ont voulu jouer au
dieu créateur en jouant fait leur
ordinateur en modifiant les conditions
initiales et lois physiques et chaque
fois ça donne un univers complètement
stérile
c'est à dire que les paramètres et oui
oui justement les lois physiques qu'on a
avec les conscientiser qu'on a
oui l'afrique gespunsart neufmanil pas
des scientifiques qui est une hypothèse
qui daignent
l'expérience est validé validation ou la
validation dire que l'état initial
permet ou pas d'obtenir l'homme en fin
de course
moi je rapporte les expériences dans
dire parce qu'on peut pas refaire le big
boi il l'hiver a été créée une fois pour
toutes on peut pas refaire le victoire
et les sauts sur ce qu'on a c'est les
ordis aux us mais moi j'aime bien
on apprend d'abord la notion de miracle
d'accord c'est à dire le miracle c'est
quelque chose qui aurait pas dû ceux qui
avaient pratiquement tout peut se
produire à condition d'atteindre comme
vous explique si on a cassé un verre il
suffit d'attendre un peu longtemps et
puis va se remettre ensemble avec
beaucoup mais pas beaucoup de temps
encore mais ça se reproduira pas
légalement avec quelque part je me
rappelle un petit peu l'admission de
vira comme ça il suffit d'attendre et
puis la probabilité extraordinaire peut
se produire
la deuxième chose que je trouve
extraordinaire je sais pas si l'on se
rappelle ce livre sap le dernier des
justes et le monde reposer sur dix 10
personnes juste dans le monde
l'acédie nombre dit constante et puis
c'est également quelques atom mais je
trouve qu'avec elle est maintenant ça
vous amuse ou ça vous savez que
j'adorais son livre j'ai rêvé avec son
livre et je sens d'ailleurs il parle de
notes de musique qui parle de quelque
chose qui est complètement mais ou du
niveau de l'humain de l'art du rêve et
ça ça me plaît beaucoup mais trinh xuan
thuan c'est vrai que vous nous raconter
c'est toujours très clair que nous
explique la physique ont tant en
contemporaine aboli la nécessité d'un
dieu donc on se dit tiens c'est son avis
le vrai coût et puis vous vous dites
et vous dites mais moi je suis prêt à
parier sur l'existence d'un être suprême
on est tout à fait étonné enfin enfin
les arguments classiques en tout cas
c'est peut-être pas les mêmes classique
d'une cause première par exemple
maintenant il ya ce qu'on appelle le
flou quantique c'est à dire on croit que
l'univers par exemple les harragas des
fluctuations quantiques quand l'univers
est très petit mais je me fais l'avocat
du diable je crois pas vraiment mais là
c'est le rallye des dieux
et non les arguments classiques ne
tiennent plus la place
mais justement cette précision de
réglages je ne crois pas que c'est dû au
hasard et vraiment je rejoins là
monsieur comme justement en tant que
praticien d'astronomie quand je vais à
mon observatoire et que je vois la
cohérence là la langue ni la beauté de
l'univers des galaxies tout ça je peux
pas croire que c'est compliqué sur du
pur au hasard oui mais des corps vous
servez vous de parler d' incohérences
pas une harmonie mais en même temps vous
nous montrez des désirs toi fais des
galaxies qui se gonflent les unes les
eaux des étoiles qui sont happés qui
disparaissent par des trous noirs et une
sorte d' une sorte de cannibalisme même
dans l'asthme hausse donc c'est tout
n'est pas remis aussi là au nom tout et
par money mais moi je parle je crois que
vraiment je pense de l'univers tend vers
une conscience paypal hand il peut y
avoir des situations et s'intéresse une
conscience qu'il faut l'appréhender
parce que je crois un nouveau sens à ses
croyances c'est pas à la science je
crois que l'univers n'a pas de sens s'il
ya personne pour l'observer qui l'a
interpellé est ce que est ce qui est un
disque de noël s'il avait une religion
je suis j'ai été élevée comme bouddhisme
mais voulait toujours
enfin je vis seul on sait pas une
religion sa philosophie
oui mais vous concilier les observations
de la science avec la philosophie du
bouddhisme long killian transcendance au
coin à droite à lacaune oui
effectivement
donc vous fait ce pari de dieu à la fin
de votre je trouve que c'est une
question intéressante parce que j'ai un
petit peu l'impression quand même que on
se trouve devant le problème
le physicien se trouve devant un
problème à cause de huit banques parce
que le physicien est habitué à cette
notion de causalité une habituée au côté
linéaire du temps et est habitué à à ce
qui est toujours justement des
conditions initiales et à partir
desquels on peut déduire le reste et
lorsqu'on arrive au big bang
effectivement il se trouve devant un
problème très difficile à résoudre
alors on appelait à dieu bon disons que
je trouve c'est un peu ça me satisfait
pas parce que si vous voulez parce qu'on
veut expliquer à un enfant quelque chose
qu'on comprend pas vraiment on lui dit
c'est parce que dieu l'a voulu
ici ça alors ça apparaît un petit peu
comme ça donc j'ai un point de vue un
peu différent
bien que je rejoigne tout à fait votre
point de vue sur le fait sur cette
harmonie qu'on ne comprend pas très bien
mais disons que mon point de vue c'est
plus de pas de faire appel à dieu ici
mais simplement de dire que à partir du
moment où on comprendra mieux oui pas
forcément les modèles qu'on est en ce
moment et c'est hélas à partir du moment
où justement on comprendra mieux un
modèle finalement c'est un pont entre ce
monde platonicien des mathématiques que
je décrivais tout à l'heure et la
réalité de la physique
et si vous voulez ce monde platonicien
des mathématiques
c'est un monde qui lui ne dépend pas de
tel ou tel modèle qui existe mais c'est
un des mots les mêmes c'est comme ça le
monde pense aux anciens et alors mon
espoir justement c'est qu'au fur et à
mesure qu'on aura mieux compris juste
nos les relations entre ces deux mondes
eh bien on n'aura plus à faire on
comprendra déjà beaucoup mieux et on
n'aura plus justement cette espèce de
sentiment de vide lorsqu'on se retrouve
pose enfin devant le jour même du big
bang
justement parce que mais c'est vrai que
vous êtes un peu pessimiste à la fin
parce que je lis la fin c'est l'univers
ne sera jamais inaccessible
la mélodie restera jamais ce que j'ai lu
votre livre s'intitule mais est ce une
raison pour se décourager pour
abandonner laquelle je ne crois pas
l'homme ne pourra jamais échappé à ce
besoin urgent ce d'organiser le monde
extérieur en et schéma cohérent et
l'univers ce schéma c'est relié aux
mathématiques on peut se demander si
dieu a créé les mathématiques d'abord
puisque c'est une espèce de réalité qui
est gris platine aux sabres c'est ça à
plein temps d'ici là le dis que c'est
sur wii
là on tombe sur un homme qui est très
important c'est à dire qu' il ya des
discours il ya des discours scientifique
qui prétend réfute et enfin démontrer
l'inexistence de dieu il ya des discours
métaphysique discours religieux par
exemple
oui mais moi ce qui me frappe finalement
c'est que
cette idée de dieu auquel je crois je
peux dire que c'est quelque chose dont
on ne peut pas parler vraiment quand on
ne peut pas vraiment parler en ce sens
que chaque fois qu'on veut le mettre
dans le temps j'étais frappé quand il
double ses curieuses dieu finalement ou
bien il est temporel il est d'un autre
temps où la roue mal
il est impuissant voilà qu'ils voient ce
monstre il est devenu bien il est
intemporel et alors qu'est ce qui peut
faire aujourd'hui on n'est rien du tout
on est une goutte d'eau dans ces 400
millions 10 heures d'année au super coq
bon il faut faire un choix
et moi je crois que c'est le discours de
l'homme comme ça à propos de dieu qui
veut le catégoriser et dans la religion
juive par exemple je connais un petit
peu
et bien justement il ne s'agit pas de
parler de mettre un nom de définir de
dessiner tout ça justement cette espèce
de nom définition le fait de ne pas
parler est une chose très importante et
je crains que l'homme ne soit toujours
obligé de parler soit démontrée
scientifiquement sur des montres habitat
physiquement les qualités du coach mais
au fond on l'a dans votre camp vous êtes
vous étudiez donc le ciel vous êtes à
l'écouté de cette musique secret voilà
exactement fond c'est votre passion dans
la vie
oui exact mais jai vous êtes vous serrez
vous admirez l'univers si vous regardez
nos errances vous savez le savez le lire
oui mais je pense que même cela va plus
loin vous êtes me sens métier amoureux
de l'univers
oui certainement oui oui c'est une
passion et chaque fois que je mets un
observatoire ce sentiment de communion
avec le cosmos me donne un sentiment
index libération et juhasz à certains et
le bras dans tout cela on n'est pas en
naîtra dans la science non non surtout
si jamais vous parler de dieu et de ses
relations avec humilité nous ne sommes
plus dans le domaine de l'acier
exactement exigences à la science mais
il est un petit peu un mélange de jeu
par la puissance de dire mais diablement
ce sont les plantes relais
les matins vous avez compris la
théologie et l'observation de l'univers
et et son analyse rigoureuse est formel
c'est un pari c'est un acte de foi mais
glacial et montrent pas là sont les 25
d'un sacré sais pas je ne prépare pas du
tout - mystique justement j'en suis
arrivée justement comme comme ceux qui
vous l'a dit très exactement j'étais
attiré par la beauté l'astrophysique
univers tout ça et j'étais pas du tout
mystique mais en l'étudiant de plus en
plus en voyant la cohérence à l'harmonie
des parfums de ses rayons sur hazard si
le voilà qu'il a c'est le cerveau ne
revient au cerveau tendu et cette année
c'est le cerveau qui la reçoit et qui
l'analysent l'étudient qui en retient
certains paramètres mais je crois qu'il
ya une réalité transcendante qui existe
un dépenses est un axe de choix où
croyez voilà oui je crois
l'occasion alors agissez part est-ce
qu'on peut être à la fois scientifique
et et faire confiance à la fois
ben je crois que les problèmes des
croyances est important et peut être
analysées scientifiquement dans une
certaine mesure dire que ce qui me
trouble dans cette discussion c'est que
on donne dans des systèmes de croyances
qui ont été mentionnés qui font partie
de ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler des
objets d'étude des sciences humaines il
existe un très grand nombre de
chercheurs dans ce domaine qui étudie
l'histoire des religions qui essayent de
situer chaque système de croyances par
rapport à la commission scientifique de
l'époque et je pense qu'on peut avoir
une vision scientifique des croyances
elles mêmes souvent le scientifique
croyant ne seront peut-être pas compte
qu'il appartient à un système de
croyance de ce type et c'est d'autant
plus important qu'il s'intéresse à des
objets qui sont éloignés de l'homme lui
même donc je crois que
il est important pour un scientifique de
se situer non seulement par rapport à sa
discipline mais aussi par rapport à
d'autres disciplines et je crois que
dans cet aéropage les sciences humaines
sont pas représentés les neurosciences
constitue une espèce de vous voulez pas
besoin de monde
non mais bien entendu mais je crois que
fenêtres ville
nous verrons oui d'un autre haye
alors c'est la dernière question est ce
qu'on a l'impression que le récit du
cosmos tels que monsieur nous le raconte
seulement l'histoire des galaxies et
modifier parce que il à la fois il nous
le révèle à la fin de son livre en un
être suprême est ce qu'il le raconterai
autres mais je pense que chacun doit
être libre
adams bianchi qui se dépassent à celle
de du scientifique lui même c'est à dire
que c'est un système de croyances oui
moi je dirais non franchement à cette
question par une loge
j'approuve la méthode scientifique je
suis scientifique et donc toutes les
choses que j'ai raconte là sont les
derniers chapitres sont des faits
scientifiques que moi c'est ça vous
mélangez pas les deux anneaux non non je
j'ai agi en tant que scientifique et
java prépare les informations en tant
que scientifique
amo jeu sans culpabilité la des
scientifiques légendaire des très gêné
de parler de deux fois deux religions
captivité un sujet tabou
moi je pense que l'éthique et la
religion peut apporter une intention un
projet et que le scientifique apports
des lumières rapports d'effets apporte
une manière de progresser par rapport
aux autres méthodes pas que les uns et
les autres se tuent veulent être résumée
la réalité car ce serait de manière trop
et je signale aux téléspectateurs que
jean pierre changeux n'est pas
pas seulement un savant j'emploie ce mot
mais mais mais aussi vous êtes un
spécialiste de l'art car vous avez
organisé vous avez le commissaire
général d'une grande exposition qui
s'est tenue au musée bossuet de mots sur
la peinture du xviie siècle et c'est
vous qui allez organiser c'est alors là
votre cerveau est aussi je pense que
votre cerveau voit l'art d'une autre
manière que les jeux parce que l'art est
une fonction est extrêmement importante
et génial un petit pour apparaître dans
les années qui viennent l'avenir
remplacer un peu la région je pense qu
on a introduit bahreïn force de
réconciliation qui au fond dépasse
toutes les croyances en ont parlé merci
alors il